don't cave and you will win because you
will wake more and more people up one of
the guys who I'm continually working on
is Bill Maher and here he is on his show
listening to Paul bagalla leftist
activist Paul De Gala who can't
understand why nothing's working right
from his own side and then bill has to
lay out some truth
and my fellow liberals it's the people
we supposedly care about are the victims
of crime it's those folks who are voting
for more security more safety more and
better cops and it's the white liberals
who want to defund the police this is a
big Achilles heel for the Democrats is
it not oh they need to get out in front
of it they need to I want a Democrat
stand up say you know some people belong
in jail
you know the rapists the murderers
I think that's very interesting I'm
gonna go out on the limb some people do
look I would have to do the whole Bill
Maher thing but you know the fact that
he even called out the one person
clapped on that that some people deserve
in jail because Liberals are all afraid
of each other if if five people had
clapped then 20 people would have
clapped and then the whole audience
would have clapped on that but there was
one same probably conservative in the
crowd here's oh rapists should be in
jail
that's pretty good
anybody for rapists in jail
and Bill's going yeah rapists should be
in jail you morons I will give Bill a
lot of credit on that he is the only
host I have ever seen in television
history who attacks his own audience
when they're being stupid now again Bill
always will vote for Democrats I'm going
to keep working on him so be it but the
point is Paul McAllen it's our guys it's
us that are doing this why don't we do
better than this well who are you always
voting for so bill needs to join
the team join the team man that rewards
those who protect us but are constantly
hated on who wrote the team that rewards
the people who are keeping Society going
while the other side decides to burn the
whole thing down
we got more DeSantis yeah he's hiring
more police officers and giving them
bonuses because they all want to move
here since they don't want to live in
New York or Cali anymore
the legislature in this legislative
session we need to do bonuses uh for law
enforcement someone to fund
[Applause]
come want to defund the police we're
funding the police and then some and
that is the Stark difference whether it
is at the education level whether it is
at the policing level that is the Stark
difference between what's happening here
in Florida and what's happening in
places like New York and California and
that's why their descent into that black
hole of Destruction
foreign
[Music]